[Música]
ambulancias y personas hospitalizadas de
urgencia por covid-19 se han convertido
en escenas más habituales que nunca en
Brasil este mes fue el más letal que ha
registrado el país desde el inicio de la
pandemia con más de 66.000 muertes en
marzo el sistema y el personal sanitario
brasileño están contra las cuerdas en
ocasiones deben elegir a qué pacientes
atender según sus probabilidades de
sobrevivir con una ocupación superior al
90% en las unidades de cuidados
intensivos de muchos estados el
Ministerio de salud teme que la
situación empeore con las festividades
de semana santa
sabemos que los grandes festivos son una
posibilidad de aglomeraciones
innecesarias las personas deben hacer
uso del tapabocas
el uso del tapabocas es importante es
fundamental tienen que mantener la
distancia entre ellas para que la
enfermedad no se transmita la velocidad
a la que lo está haciendo
una demanda que parece podrá decir a la
de bolsonaro que pidió a los Estados
federales que permitan que la gente
vuelva al trabajo para reactivar la
economía nacional
esta política de aislamiento estas
medidas restrictivas y el toque de queda
con la supresión del derecho a ir y
venir va mucho más allá Incluso el
estado de sitio hago un llamado a todas
las autoridades de Brasil para que
revisen esta política y permitan que la
gente vaya a trabajar
lento avance de la vacunación con un 8%
de la población inoculada y la
restricciones poco respetadas no han
logrado contener el número de muertes
diarias en las últimas 24 horas Brasil
registró un nuevo récord con más de
3.800 decesos Lejos de ser
esperanzadores los expertos aseguran que
abril será otro mes duro para la nación